mert ameddig ott van a két tej és egy
párkapcsolatban hogy hogy ha elég
őszinte vagyok hogy ha igazán elmondom a
gondolataimat lehet hogy itt fogsz
hagyni akkor akkor nem fogok őszinte
lenni viszont hogyha azt látom hogy ezt
a problémát vagy megoldjuk vagy
megőrülünk tehát nincs kiút ebből tehát
az eskü kötelez akkor akkor meg kell
oldjuk és akkor akkor ez a krízis kell
ahhoz hogy hogy hogy az legmélyebb
legfájobb dolgokhoz is belemenjünk és és
és meg megpróbáljuk megold mert ameddig
nincs ez a krízis ameddig mindig van egy
menekülő úton addig addig álltatjuk
magunkat védi az egónk a a személyünket
hogy ne kelljen változzunk és az az az a
személy aki ezt nem gondolja komolyan
aki ezt az esküt úgy mondja ki hogy
felületesen lehet nem is volt házas soha
lehet hogy formálisan azt mondták hogy
házasok de a házasság akkor kezdődik
amikor halál komolyan gondolja két fél
azt hogy holtomiglan holtodiglan nem
fogsz tudni semmit tenni hogy én itt
hagyjalak és és ez ezt a következő 50-60
évre szól